alors nous allons faire ce soir un blind
test spécial pluie inutile d'expliquer
pourquoi
mais pour arbitrer le blind test
j'appelle ma sueur philémon mortier
messieurs
attention spéciale cuir aujourd'hui on
va jouer avec les ombres est évidemment
très nombreux chinois la rebond soir
alors je vais delphine ici en blanc oui
et puis la jolie nadia aussi en moi on
va très bien donc on joue les couleurs
contre le blanc d'accord donc c'est
spécial pluie vous connaissez le
principe vous me donnez l'interprète
évidemment pas du tout le titre de la
chanson uniquement l'interprète de la de
l'accouchement vivier de la ville puis
fatigue du mois chez fred astaire
justement paraissait toujours attention
didier
gingras
la pluie
le choc
nous avons
bien ça fait un partout donc merci à
fait d'accord s'ils ont marqué les
points on continue didier prins plus
grand bravo
je demande un rythme et je veux revoir
ça je me rendais au moins mon école à
pied nourrit première à corps et votre
mépris
serge khalfon samplés replay d'environ
continue didier attention regardez le
regarde plus
bien alors l'interpellent oui oui
l'interprète
et
avec des musiques de votre époque mais
avant ça c'est encore pire ce qui arrive
là didier un terme à trois dj bobo
et oui sans son numéro 6 nougaro nougaro
mai dernier c'est une des médias
et se renier
oh
bravo
et c'est un jeu d'équipé a fini jeudi
que le collectif fonctionne rabattant
aimé jacquet
alors c'est pas ça ici et il y est
parvenu
bah oui les chansons et les écrits
l'habitude d'être ouvert
alors la suite vide et il pleuvra avec
lui 24/10 du savon
à dix on cherche une majorité bien
maintenant il ya le superbe mais c'est
la règle du jeu
ceux qui trouvent le super banco gagne
tout même si l'organisme maintenant
arrêter quoi bon jouer c'est injuste
mais super banco connaît at on attend
deux compères
la région
les faits
addendum bravo vous appelez comment mais
c'est qui l'éruption
pourquoi
vite et de la chance qu'ils avaient du
fort à faire avec les superbes anthony
watts seuls les très fréquenté mais
voilà seillier tournant par l'émission
pas comme les autres michèle bernier
les histoires d'amour peuvent toujours
bien si mal il va manquer le compteur à
tout le monde
voilà la cassette vidéo et voilà le dvb
à toulouse à toulouse 30 et 31 et
l'olympia du 29 janvier au 3 février
2010 voilà didier deschamps et dominique
bouche voilà vainqueur dans l'âme aux
éditions à et des champs contrechamps
sur pépé foot la skip eric hamdi la
maison de prêt à venir à la vue du film
x men
montparnasse infernale le buzz du marbre
à l'héparine à pois est certes rien ou
qu'il allait tombera martinez
en journée les maximales avec balle sort
isabelle carré et vous êtes seul membre
du jury du festival de dubaï du vin
d'estaing au 3 avril
merci avec des caddies indiqué maryline
abdallah saleh le chanteur français
signalons trop long il est mort le
chanteur voile à wimereux shanghai daily
aux éditions picquier voilà c'était
doullens par l'émission pas comme les
autres à sa motion